Wow oh oh no no no you know what
[Applause]
need that and now the official step in
CJ
takes issue with
that quickly escalated
fists
here they were they take a look as of
course in defense in saqqaq as well and
the officials here tonight as well
quickly
looks like it starts off with the men
trying to set a screen
[Applause]
CJ meets him with the ride-on just to
try to navigate the screen
it shoves him and another chef
another show and then it quickly
escalated from there
where the hands were balled up but there
were no fish thrown
is just another day in the backyard for
CJ Canton Ohio with his brother air
which is going at it
[Applause]
get to this level by being a finesse
player that way
Glenna 70 around America
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to save a step in
he backs off CJ
that will take care of
[Applause]
[Music]
and officials quickly diffused the
situation on the floor now their survey
[Music]
[Applause]
mid-flow watch with that left hand
I would say no
let's see that again once wasn't luck
don't have a half-hearted jab baby
I have harder but it still to town
players have their hands
of course from CJ hit the West land up
on both hands up got to jab
kind of a weak little lead
it's the automatic ejection whether a
punch connects or not
[Music]
they're calling it offensive foul on
Atlanta double technicals so on
and on CJ
so simply offsetting technical fouls
double meaning to not double technical
best ejection on the play
so they're saying nope much
big question is now what does this mean
as a pertains to the game does this fire
up the Blazers in a way that they go on
a run we certainly hope so
[Applause]